President Trump said and he said this
very seriously that he wants the United
States to buy Greenland he wants the
u.s. to purchase Greenland and he said
that and people thought he was kidding
he wasn't kidding he really wants us to
buy Greenland in response
meda Frederickson the prime minister of
Denmark which controls Greenland said
the idea is absurd
well this angered President Trump so he
tweeted that he's postponing an upcoming
visit to Denmark yes because he's angry
well guess what this infuriated Denmark
because it's an insult to their queen
mark Reeth ii who extended the
invitation to trump and today in
reaction to Denmark's anger Trump said
the Prime Minister's response to him was
quote nasty yeah so now the whole thing
is a big mess it's just it's just it's a
I mean it's a [ __ ] show right right
right
I'm using these words always it fought
who would have thought yeah everyone's
mad at everybody over this initial idea
but I'm gonna say something that no
one's saying in the press because a lot
of the people were of going against
Trump President Trump knows real estate
if he knows anything it's real estate
and I personally as a citizen think he
might be onto something I think the u.s.
buying Greenland is a great idea and all
this angry back-and-forth is just
classic haggling over a real estate
purchase this is what people do hmm
every side play is hard to get right so
to make sure this purchase goes through
here's what I'm doing I'm gonna travel
to Greenland as part of Conan Without
Borders
you can follow me as it happens I'm Team
Coco calm yeah I'm gonna go there I'm
gonna kick the tires on this deal and
I'm gonna get this deal done that's the
plan now thank you very much one person
out of 300 those are pretty good odds
for me you know I've been giving it a
lot of thought buying a property the
size of Greenland is a huge huge
undertaking there's a lot of money
involved and I wanted to make sure I'm
getting the us a good deal that's why
tonight I'm gonna get some advice on
buying Greenland from a top real estate
team they're watched in more than 160
countries here via satellite
it's drew and Jonathan Scott from HGTV's
property brothers okay well thanks for
helping me out guys I really appreciate
it thanks for each chances Conan yeah
buying Greenland is a pretty huge
investment yeah and for some people
buying green light is the largest
financial decision of their lives now
drew you're the real estate market
expert is this a good buy it's all about
location Conan I checked it out your
nearest neighbors are Canada and Iceland
and they're both pretty quiet okay well
Jonathan you're the licensed contractor
how's the island structurally I actually
went over to Greenland this morning just
to take a look and here's what I would
suggest I would knock out this bleh sure
just to get a more open-concept plan and
add a kitchen island definitely we'll do
a fire pit in the back with lots of
seating and if you want maybe knock this
mountain out of here so you'd have more
natural light coming in from the north
side naturally will also make it feel a
lot bigger all right that is that's
really great advice thank you very much
guys also if you're gonna buy Greenland
I suggest buying Iceland as well because
it would make a great mother-in-law
suite or is thinking future resale value
again terrific advice thank you very
much guys
jihwan Jonathan Scott the property
brothers we're gonna get this done what
you doing when you go in